a bottle smashes and a ship gets its
name Danish and European officials
gathered on Thursday for a ceremony that
goes back to Viking times but one that
could now put modern vessels into battle
against climate change by successfully
decarbonizing shipping we're not only
promoting our fight against climate
change we're also creating new Supply
Chains new Industries and thousands of
new Goods
jobs the ship owned by Danish cargo
giant MK is set to emit 100 tons of
carbon dioxide less per day than a
diesel one it runs on green methanol
produced from decomposed organic waste
120 more vessels are now in the pipeline
from other companies green methanol has
been around for a long time but it isn't
cheap the Danish State hopes that by
commissioning vessels powered by
methanol it will Kickstart production
lower prices and begin to challenge the
dominance of fossil fuels
oet yon neelson has a share in a Nobel
Peace Prize thanks to his work with the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change he believes methanol can fulfill
the ambition to reduce shipping
emissions by more than
60% but that will need sources more
diverse than mesque suppliers in the
Netherlands and fossil fuel is a
hydrocarbon methanol is also a
hydrocarbon it's a small molecule the
thing is that you can make green
methanol in different ways in the Middle
East you got a lot lot of sun and a lot
of areas for solar panels so why not
produce green methanol in the Middle
East where all the ships are sailing
around anyway environmental campaigners
still say a key way to reduce emissions
is to reduce dependence on fuel burning
transport like ships and cars but as the
United Nations targets net zero
emissions in the shipping industry by
2050 green methanol is being welcomed it
is a big a step forward compared to
where the sector has been and has been
stuck for for many years with fossil
fuels but this this isn't an example of
greenwashing I don't think so because if
you look at what can shipping uh do
today there is really no better solution
for for big cargo ships with Scientists
warning of a Tipping Point in how much
pollution the planet can handle building
on the early promise of methanol could
have a deadly urgency Paul ree aler
Copenhagen make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer